hola bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
la entrevista de france 24 en español en
esta oportunidad nos acompaña erick iván
ortiz el ex secretario de comunicaciones
de la federación salvadoreña el fbi y
también es director de asuntos políticos
del partido nuestro tiempo eric
muchísimas gracias por tu presencia en
la entrevista de france 24
un saludo santiago de gracias a france
24 por permitirme dirigirme hoy a su
audiencia no gracias a boselli curar es
más bueno el salvador se encuentra desde
marzo bajo un régimen de excepción que
fue decretado por el gobierno de nayib
que le bajo el argumento de combatir la
violencia entre pandillas que para
finales de ese mes dejaba decenas de
muertos pero contanos cómo afecta en
particular esta medida a la población
lgp y qu más
yo creo que hay que entender justamente
esto que decías el régimen de excepción
es el último resultado de un gobierno
antidemocrático que paulatinamente ha
venido desmantelando todo el sistema
democrático institucional en el salvador
hoy por hoy el gobierno salvadoreño
encabezado por nadie buque le controla
los tres poderes del estado y esto es
importante para poder entender cuál es
el contexto que entonces sufrimos las
poblaciones en condición de
vulnerabilidad es cierto que la
violencia ha sido un fenómeno
estructural que nos atraviesa a los
países del triángulo norte de
centroamérica desde hace mucho tiempo
pero que particularmente hacia las
personas elegía las poblaciones en
condición de vulnerabilidad siempre es
un riesgo añadido sin embargo hoy cuando
hay una argumentación que el gobierno
utiliza para con estas y llamada guerra
contra las pandillas lo que vemos es un
riesgo particular hacia las
organizaciones defensoras de derechos
humanos porque son éstas las que están
señalando la violación sistemática de
derechos humanos que está ocasionando el
gobierno de nayib o que le
particularmente con las detenciones
arbitrarias y la negación de los
derechos constitucionales
proceso y por señalar estas violaciones
de derechos humanos entonces el
presidente ha enfocado a las
organizaciones defensoras de derechos
humanos entre ellas el eje vete y las
del movimiento feminista como defensores
de los pandillas como vemos es otra
estrategia más del gobierno salvadoreño
por construir una narrativa de buenos y
malos y por supuesto entre los malos
estamos las personas lgtb y que estamos
nada más que reivindicando nuestros
derechos como lo hemos hecho con el
resto de gobiernos en el salvador pérez
gracias referencia recién a lo que es el
contexto no en el que está ocurriendo
todo esto ahora previo a la declaración
del estado de excepción ya el gobierno
de nayib vu que le había emitido alguna
serie de políticas que arremetieron de
alguna manera contra los derechos del
colectivo por ejemplo se eliminaron
instituciones estatales que mantenían
los derechos lg vete y comas en las en
las agendas cuales fueron erick los
principales retrocesos y qué efectos
tuvieron desde la llegada de google al
poder
de forma contundente la llegada de nage
bukele al poder ha significado un
retroceso para los derechos de las
personas lgtb y hacemos un análisis en
el que estoy implicado alrededor de un
retroceso de 10 años de lucha organizada
porque decimos esto porque desde hace 10
años en la población el gp y logró ser
verbalizada nombrada fue al centro del
estado en el que el gobierno de ese
entonces empezó una serie de políticas
importantes para las personas lgtb y
desde el inicio de la presidencia de
mayo bukele lo que hemos visto es una un
desmantelamiento sistemático de
cualquier avance que las personas el
gente y podríamos haber reconocido
dentro de ministerios clave como el
ministerio de seguridad el ministerio de
educación el ministerio de trabajo y el
ministerio de salud sin embargo quizás
lo más significativo ha sido no de parte
del gobierno específicamente sino de la
asamblea legislativa que también
controlan y es que el año pasado esta
asamblea legislativa archivó la ley de
identidad de género y una ley especial
contra la discriminación dos
anteproyectos que la bancada de nuevas
ideas la bancada del presidente
obsoletas y no acordes a la realidad y
como un carpetazo tan sencillo como eso
decidió seguirle negando
sistemáticamente derechos a las personas
trans con una ley de identidad pero
también a todas las poblaciones en
condiciones de vulnerabilidad al no
reconocer que la discriminación es un
fenómeno que enfrentamos mujeres
juventudes personas con discapacidad
afrodescendencia y por supuesto las
personas en el gp y en resumen lo que
vemos es la consolidación de un gobierno
anti derechos que hoy por hoy representa
una amenaza sin precedentes para las
personas el gp y en el salvador
eric desde lo que es tu activismo
articular muchísimas con movimientos de
otros países de américa latina que vimos
en argentina y uruguay en distintos
países que pero qué particularidades
encontradas en términos tanto de
derechos y conquistas como de
vulneraciones en la región en particular
de centroamérica
yo creo que lo más significativo es que
estamos frente a una embestida
conservadora es decir este es el
resultado de un movimiento reaccionario
frente al avance de los derechos de
mujeres y personas se aleje de ti y lo
que vemos es cada vez más como estos
grupos anti derechos obtienen mayor
financiamiento pero más peligroso aún
luego tienen la corresponsalía el
soporte de algunos partidos ultras de
ultraderecha o de anti derechos que han
estado asumiendo sus agendas y porque
esto es importante o porque es tan
peligroso y es que lo que estamos viendo
a lo largo de américa latina pero
también en el mundo entero es como el
discurso de odio ese discurso de
división pero sobre todo un discurso que
se enfoca en las personas el gmt y para
convertirles en un blanco de la
violencia se está institucionalizando y
conforme avanza el tiempo también se han
convertido en dianas políticas y
electorales en diversos países entonces
lo que estamos viendo es como las
personas el gmt y las mujeres y algo
señalamiento porque somos dos grupos que
estamos bajo la diana del
conservadurismo más rancio y
recalcitrante de la región y eso
encontramos en diversos países
justamente tenido la oportunidad desde
el global equality que es donde soy
coordinador de membresías y programas de
articular el lanzamiento del capítulo
américa latina y justamente esto lo que
trata es de dar una respuesta coordinada
porque hay que entender que hace un
sistema de opresión una un auge de la
narrativa en contra de derechos no es
una novedad para las personas lgtb y lo
que sí es una novedad y ese es el factor
positivo es que hoy por hoy hay un
número importante de personas el gmt y
en cargo de elección popular en puestos
de poder un movimiento el gp y vibrante
vemos como en diferentes países de
américa latina pero también el mundo las
marchas del orgullo lgtb y son las que
más convocan ciudadanía en las calles en
un momento en el que la legitimidad
política de muchas instituciones está en
duda y entonces mi respuesta es este es
el mejor momento hemos estado en esta es
la forma en la que mejor preparado en el
tiempo en el que mejor preparados hemos
estado para dar una respuesta pero esta
respuesta debe de ser coordinada y
volviendo a algo que nos ha hecho
fuertes a las personas lgtb y durante
todas estas décadas que es la creación
de comunidad la creación de comunidad
nos permite articular y avanzar en
conjunto frente a una amenaza que nos
supera con creces pero que seguramente
la resiliencia de la que hemos
demostrado a lo largo de nuestra
historia nos ayudará a seguir dando esta
lucha por nuestros derechos hablando de
esta lucha por sus derechos serie crees
que la oposición más fuerte al gobierno
ni nadie bukele son las organizaciones
defensoras de derechos humanos de
derechos de la población lgbt
son el adversario de bucle yo lo que
creo es que hay un contexto global otra
vez en el que hay una puesta en duda de
muchas de las postulados de la
democracia liberal en la que se suponía
que la democracia iba a ser este
ascensor social y esta garantía del
acceso a los derechos no ha sido el caso
y entonces lo que vemos a este ha sido
el resultado de un proceso de
deslegitimación donde muchas
instituciones donde los partidos
políticos han sido claras damnificados
en este proceso y el resultado ha sido
que han sido los movimientos sociales
los que ponen ahora el dedo en la yaga y
también la velocidad de la oposición al
gobierno tengo decir que la marcha del
orgullo recientemente celebrada en el
salvador el pasado 25 de junio ha sido
la marcha más multitudinaria que ha
visto el salvador en los años recientes
y eso habla justamente de un movimiento
vibrante pero sobre todo un movimiento
que se reconoce como intersección al es
decir esta no es una lucha solo de las
personas gays lesbianas bisexuales y
trans es una lucha que abarca a
diferentes poblaciones en condición de
vulnerabilidad y para las que la
violencia y la discriminación ha sido
justamente un obstáculo para poder
ejercer los derechos más básicos y lo
que vimos en la marcha del orgullo en el
salvador en este 2022 fue eso una unión
de diversos sectores en el que el
movimiento lgtb encuentra una cuerda
miento social y yo creo que esto es
importante porque en el salvador en
centroamérica y a lo largo de américa
latina- estamos librando un pulso por
reconstruir las sociedades y creo que
las mujeres y las personas lgtbi estamos
muy bien posicionados para poder ser
artífices y partícipes de esta
reconstrucción del relato democrático
que va a sacar adelante a nuestros
pueblos
eric hablemos de un hecho muy
preocupante hace pocos meses denunciaste
que recibiste dos llamadas con amenazas
de muerte se puede morir en el salvador
por luchar por los derechos lgtb y por
supuesto de hecho en la impunidad
rampante en el salvador casos tan
emblemáticos como defensoras de france
la méndez entre otras que han sido
víctimas justamente en su condición de
defensoras y defensores de derechos
humanos de las personas lgtb y han sido
víctimas de homicidios lo que hemos
visto lejos de un acompañamiento de los
sistemas de seguridad pública hemos
visto cómo han sido construidas como
adversarios y revictimizando les y más
bien lo que se ha consolidado es un
sistema de impunidad y por supuesto lo
que me sucedió a mí es lo que le sucede
a diferentes actores que desarrollamos
la defensa de los derechos humanos en el
salvador y sobre todo hoy por hoy en el
que el presidente de la república nadie
bukele nos ha posicionado como
adversario de la historia como
adversario y enemigo del país cuando en
la práctica lo único que estamos
haciendo es señalándole y poniéndole el
dedo en la llaga de la violación
sistemática de derecho humanos y
recordándole que este es un país que
tiene memoria y que lo que estamos
viendo hoy es algo que ya vivimos antes
y que nos desembocó en una cruenta
guerra civil no queremos regresar a eso
el país dijo nunca más y las personas el
gp y las mujeres vamos a estar en pie de
lucha al frente si es necesario también
para mantener también esta lucha que
seguimos y que seguramente continuará a
pesar de las amenazas del régimen de
nadie bukele nos queda menos de un
minuto algunos 30 ó 40 segundos pero no
quiero dejar de preguntarte de lo
siguiente esta situación tienes
información se ha generado algún tipo de
desplazamiento forzado de la población
lgp y q por supuesto de hecho el
desplazamiento forzado es un fenómeno
que venimos viviendo la población
salvadoreña en términos generales y que
el estado salvadoreño no ha querido
reconocer sin embargo existe
desplazamiento forzado por el régimen de
excepción que ahora tenemos con cada bis
trans documenta al igual que cristo sal
decenas de casos de personas el fbi pero
también un sinnúmero de otras personas
es que hay que decirlo estamos en un
régimen de excepción que acá más de 40
mil personas en tres meses y muchísimos
de estos casos son
detenciones arbitrarias y no no han
llevado ningún debido proceso hoy por
hoy en el salvador las personas son
culpables hasta que se demuestra lo
contrario es decir todo al revés
entonces estamos viviendo sin lugar a
dudas un desafío formidable pero también
estoy convencido de que la población
salvadoreña y particularmente las
personas lgp y estamos en las
condiciones para dar defensa lucha y
vamos a seguir resistiendo como lo hemos
venido haciendo las últimas décadas
erick iván ortiz muchísimas gracias por
tu presencia en la entrevista de france
24 en español gracias a ustedes santiago
un gusto gracias a ti una llamada hacia
nuestra audiencia y le invitamos a que
sigan informando se en el resto de
nuestra programación y en france mit y
cuatro.com sigan junto de nosotros
[Música]